okay now yesterday we were trying to
remember and trying to dig back because
you've known algebra for so long right
algebra is the mathematics of what is
that word starting with a P that we dug
into yesterday premium rules right which
is about when you've got letters already
symbols really that stand for numbers
that's what pruning world meets stands
for numbers now algebra therefore is
really the mathematics of numbers you
don't know you don't know what their
value is or they now you can change so
that's why we put letters in their place
okay now what I want to point out to you
on this yellow laminated thing which you
are the only the second years you never
had something like this this is what we
call the reference shape underneath this
heading how much you got make a point
for yourself which is download and print
the reference change the reference sheet
is what you will get during your
assessments including the final HSC you
can see we've tried our best it's three
pages it's three pages so there's the
first pair of pages which are about
mathematics to unit so we've just kind
of fit them all in and then the third
page or the reverse is extension one
I'll get to that in a second and you
will get this in every single assessment
that you do throughout the year okay
which is why I physically brought these
I'm gonna click me back obviously but
these are what you get so we can reuse
them why do we have a reference sheet
how many of you study physics physics
you huge project thinking there's now in
physics you also have a sheet that's
quite similar has a different name
Dada sheet something like that okay why
do we have these kinds of things doing
assessments actual question to you guys
why do these things exist yeah
okay fantastic so number one there are
things that you can confuse back and
forth between things for example in
mathematics when we use the letter M it
always always stands for there's any
other usually gradient but in physics it
usually stands for and think about a
physics thing that starts with M usually
mass right you can think about the
letter 8 what does the letter a stand
for in physics usually I mean come on
the most famous equation in the world is
a equals MC squared so that's energy but
in mathematics it never means energy it
either means they don't know what it
usually means a just little oh that's
Biggie's if anyway that's a letter if
either refers to this no mom very or it
stands for something called eccentricity
which I can explain way before you want
okay so good first point so you don't
confuse them in other reasons why we as
teachers
uh-huh so memory matters in all subjects
right you have to remember some stuff in
order to fact come first then skills
using those facts okay but memory is not
primarily what matters is about and
that's it's about thinking it's
recognizing patent it's about
understanding in solving problems
so therefore being that memory is not
really what we're assessing we try and
take memory as much as we can out of the
equation okay
anyhow so there's lots of things that we
judge expect you to remember however I
just want you to look let's just start
with the first page okay you actually
know quite a few of these things already
you're like wow this is really stage six
just just go through and mentally check
off the things that you already know and
recognize factorization those look
really remember this look familiar yeah
yeah they should look familiar right
though these actually all have names
under factorization the first one is
very very first one a squared minus B
squared we usually call that difference
of squares the next two they're not
square as they are cubed so we call them
when you add remember we looked at this
yesterday one a the sum and difference
of cubes okay good
what about the next one have we seen
that before we have by the way why is it
true if I gave you like say a Pentagon
right the reason we can know that it's
angle sum is 540 degrees is because of
this boy oh but what is this formula
come from does anyone actually remember
banana
past what is who is Pascal face or what
shape triangles believe me we'll talk
about past I was playing with a second
but just raking the triangles actually
what I'm interested in here does any I
remember the trick that we look we used
to find out what these five angles add
up to come on think if you just divide
up this shape into triangles right
how many trailers can fit three because
there are one two three four five sides
so you can fit three okay and each of
those three triangles has an angle some
odd degrees
can you see it now you see it n minus
two like five minus two and each 180 is
it straight so you know that keep going
equation of circle we've seen up for
hope so okay and you can keep going go
through this with me now I said you guys
are only the second year to have
something like this back in my day we
did get some sort of memory aid but all
that was on here was I want you to look
at this side see that fourth column the
final column over there you see how it's
got these um we symbols there that maybe
you haven't seen at all they look like
this she does okay that's what we call
the integral sign I'll explain those
later this year that's why they're
heading some integrals okay on our sheet
my she had nine or ten of those results
like actually including these okay and
that was my whole shape that was it
everything else had to be up here okay
now let me say it's very carefully put
your shake down from
the two facing pages the the two unit
okay of sheets they're not for you
I mean you can use them but they are not
for you because honestly by the time we
get to all these assessments than that
kind of thing what happens when you use
a piece of knowledge or immediately but
you do exercise this you look it over
there again what happens to that you
just learned it like you're not
purposely like all I should cover it up
memorize covered up that you just learn
it almost by accident okay now as
students in x3 for the two unit course
that should be everyone in this room
should be ever in this room we give this
to you which is kind of handy but as you
can imagine if you are in an exam and
you see a question and you're like oh
what do I have to do for this one right
if you have to consult this that doesn't
come for free it comes with a time
penalty you've got to know what you're
looking for then you've got to find it
then you've got to apply it okay for
students in your position by the time we
start to use these most of these should
be in your memory not because you've
made a special effort to memorize but
because you'll know them now okay Tohno
this is where it starts to get a little
more gray okay so this stuff
whoa we don't know any of this stuff not
really anywhere okay now we will learn
and master all of these I'll forgive you
a little more if you want to consult
this side to be honest I wish I really
wish I had this side when I was going
through but this is not something we'll
have to worry about for a little while
okay but you get them all together so
that's why I'm showing you the whole
thing okay